أنا أحب القهوة نعم نعم
لقد كنت أبحث
عن المكان المثالي
، الشيء الرائع في دبي هو أن لديك
الكثير من الخيارات ولكني كنت أبحث
عن التخصص على وجه الخصوص
وتعثرت عبر الخام ،
شكرًا لك إنه مكان خاص
[موسيقى]
لا يمكنني الحصول عليه أبدًا  جيد كما هو الحال هنا ،
لقد حصلت على الضجة المعتادة في
المقهى مع استمرار الأشياء
لديك ،
لكن الشيء العظيم هنا هو أنهم يقومون بتدريب
جمعية القهوة المتخصصة الأمريكية
جيدًا ، لقد أذهلني الأمر تمامًا
.  بلغت الخمسين من
العمر هذا العام ، ويبدو الأمر وكأنني
لم أكن أستخدم حواسي في محاولة
لتحديد نوع القهوة
الذي تستخدمه في الملعقة
التي تستنشقها للحصول على تدفق
الهواء ثم بصقها من
حيث التفاصيل
المعرفة ليس لدي هوية  كيف
كان الأمر علميًا في
العادة ، فأنا هنا كل يوم
كان لدي نوع جميل
من الشعور الحقيقي الأصيل ،
كما تعلمون مباشرة من المزارعين إلى
دبي ، حيث
يقومون بتحميصها وهو علم
ومهارة ربما قليلاً من الفن
المهارة هناك أيضًا والأجواء التي
أعتقد أنها خلقت شيئًا
فريدًا حقًا هنا ،
نعم لم أر شيئًا آخر مثل